alors fatima pour vous il faut stopper
ce concours miss france oui je pense
qu'effectivement dans quelques années on
se dira peut-être en 2010 9 ans faisait
encore un concours pour mettre en
concurrence des femmes sur la base de
leur physique et sur des critères
extrêmement restrictif en effet et pour
moi le concours miss france qui a un
côté très solonnel très cérémonieux qui
est un grand rendez vous une fois par an
mine de rien il a un énorme effet parce
qu'il rappelle qu est-ce que censé être
une femme belle donc avec tout un tas de
critères comme j'hésiterais respire très
restrictif la minceur le style
vestimentaire qui ne doit pas déborder
l'âge une belle femme est censée dun le
maintien latitude mais aussi
qu'est-ce-qui censé être une femme bien
une femme fréquentable c'est à dire on
va aussi les juger sur leurs moeurs et
c'est pour ça qu'on a parfois des
moments très durs de presque répudiation
quand il ya eu typiquement la sphère
verts valérie bègue où il ya eu des
photos en plus contre son consentement
qui sont sortis montrant des photos
osées donc c'est bien une cérémonie qui
est archaïque parce que c'est un
héritage qui rappelle un peu c'est quoi
la petite fiancée modèle de la nation en
fait et c'est important pour moi de dire
quand même parce que en tant qu
associative et notamment parce que j'ai
été dans une association on avait
affaire à beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui
les jeunes femmes et beaucoup viennent
témoigner entre l'unissent france la
publicité les magazines féminins qu
elles ont l'impression en regardant lui
remirent voir quelle voie des monstres
elles ont l'impression que le cri père
d'une femme acceptable et tout le temps
rabâcher étant celui là du moment
qu'elles sont un peu plus ronde et quand
je dis ronde c'est vraiment déjà
exagérée et ben elles ne sont plus la
femme avec respectant le minimum
critères de beauté et ses extrêmes ça
amène vraiment d'aider des pratiques et
des comportements à risques alimentaires
des jeunes filles qui vont acheter des
médicaments un peu de merde sur internet
pour grandir très vite des filles qui
vont avoir recours de plus en plus
jeunes même à de la chirurgie esthétique
et donc c'est important de voir quel est
l'effet que ça et sur ce qu'est censé
être une femme belle là aussi selon des
critères extrêmement restrictif et ce
qui est censé être une femme bien donc
pas de tatouage si tu as les cheveux
rasés
secours si tu veux mettre des piercings
etc et alors là si tu fais des photos
osées tu es plus dans la case connaît un
peu la société sexiste qui est là il ya
deux cases binaire les femmes qui se
respecte bien et puis les autres basse
et les femmes qui se respecte pas les
[ __ ] du bo